le maestro gérard daniel n'est plus j'ai
à donner à ne pas manger de niche il a
été retrouvé mort dans un atelier qui se
substitue au dos du club rassis kréyol à
new york
apparemment il n'y avait pas de
chauffage dans cet atelier c'est la
raison à laquelle pour la première
action c'est une raison de fois qu'il a
été retrouvé mort musicien de talent
avec son saxophone et à travers ses
nombreuses propositions
il a marqué de son empreinte la musique
de la caraïbe et aux états unis
né en 1956 à haïti gérard daniel à son
adolescence commencé à jouer avec une
très bonne formation haïti-
il a retrouvé l'équipe à 2
deiss le avec une seule comme
comme une sorte de hasard parce que l
eau des chances et de vin
devin jouer avec h le cheveu mais y
avait un problème on a dû emmener gerra
aux côtés du maire sur dallas jack
amende et c'était là l'histoire déjà
daniel a dû commencer avec la troisième
génération des cheveux cheveux
en 1974 il monte le groupe des six il
envoie un succès sur succès sa
réputation est si grande qui est
surnommé préfet debout clean il a connu
la martinique offert plusieurs concerts
reçu dans plusieurs radios camarades
younès sa disparition a surpris plus de
vingt grands saxophonistes et bourré de
talent géant dernier l'a marqué toute
une génération à travers de haut niveau
de saxe ses propositions en martinique
d'ailleurs jeudi après midi le président
du compas ricardo sur sa radio lui
rendra un vibrant hommage lors d'une
émission qui lui sera spécialement des
guides
moi